let's say I've got me a set of vectors
so let me call my set B and let's say I
have the vectors v1 v2 all the way to
through VK now let's say this isn't just
any set of vectors or some interesting
things about these vectors the first
thing is that all of these guys have
length of one so we could say the length
the length of vector V I is equal to 1
for I is I is equal to well we could say
between 1 and K or I is equal to 1 2 all
the way to K all of these guys have
lengths equal 1 or another way to say it
is that the square of their lengths are
1 the square of VI so length is equal to
1 or VI dot VI is equal to 1 for I is
you know any of these guys any I can be
1 2 3 all the way to K for I is equal to
1 2 all the way to K so that's the first
interesting thing about it let me write
in regular words all the vectors all the
vectors in B have length length 1 or
another way to say it is that they've
all been normalized that's another way
to say that is that they have all been
normalized or they're all unit vectors
normalized vectors or vectors that
you've made their lengths 1 you've
turned them into unit vectors they have
all been normalized they have all been
normalized so that's the first
interesting thing about my set B and
then the next interesting thing about my
set B is that all of the vectors are
orthogonal to each other so if you
dotted with itself so if you dot a
vector with itself you get length 1 but
if you take a vector and you dot it with
any other vector if you take VI and you
were to dot it with V J so if you
typical you know v2 and dotted v1 it's
going to be equal to 0 for
I does not equal J it's going to be zero
all of these guys are orthogonal let me
write that down all all of the vectors
are orthogonal to each other orthogonal
to each other each other and of course
they're not diagonal to themselves
because they all have length one so if
you take the dot product with itself you
get 1 if you take a dot product with the
some other guy in your set you're going
to get 0 or maybe I we can write it this
way VI dot VJ for all the members of the
set is going to be equal to it equals 0
for I does not equal J and then if these
guys are the same vector I'm dotting
with myself I'm going to have length 1
so it would equal length 1 for I is
equal to J so I've got a special set all
of these guys have length 1 and they are
all orthogonal with each other they're
normalized and they're all orthogonal
and we have a special word for this this
is called an ortho now orthonormal set
so B is an ortho ortho for orthogonal
orthonormal set orthonormal set normal
for normalize everything is orthogonal
they're all orthogonal relative to each
other and everything has been normalized
everything has length 1 now the first
interesting thing about an orthonormal
set is that it's also going to be a
linearly independent set so B so if V is
orthonormal B is also going to be
linearly linearly independent
independent and how can I show that to
you well let's assume that it isn't
linearly independent let's assume so
we're clearly all of you know let me
take let me take you know V I let me
take VJ that are members of my set and
let's assume that I does not equal that
I does not
well J now we already know that's an
orthonormal set
so VI dot VJ VI dot VJ is going to be
equal to zero they're orthogonal these
are two vectors in my set now let's
assume that they are linearly dependent
I want to prove that they're linearly
independent and the way I'm going to
prove that is by assuming they're
linearly dependent and then arriving at
a contradiction and then arriving at a
contradiction so let's assume let's
assume that VI and VJ are linearly sorry
linearly dependent linearly dependent
well then that means that I can
represent one of these guys as a scalar
multiple of the other and I can pick
either way so let's just say for the
sake of argument that I can represent VI
let's say that VI is equal to some
scalar C times V J times V J that's what
linear dependency means that one of them
can be represented as a scalar multiple
of the other well if this is true then I
can just substitute this back in for V I
and what do I get I get C times V J
which is just another way of writing V I
because I assumed linearly linear
dependence that dot VJ dot VJ has got to
be equal to zero this guy was V I this
is V J they're orthogonal to each other
but this right here is just equal to C
times V J dot VJ
which is just equal to C times the
length of V J V J squared and that has
to equal zero right they're orthogonal
so has to be equal to zero which implies
which implies that the length of V J has
to be equal to zero if we assume that
this is some non-zero multiple and this
has to be some nonzero flesh-eater for
it there C does not equal zero why does
this have to be a nonzero multiple
because these were both nonzero vectors
this is a non zero vector so this guy
can't be zero this guy has length one so
this is a nonzero vector there's no way
that I could just put a zero here
because if I put a zero then I would get
zero vectors so secant be zero so see
isn't zero then this guy right here has
to be zero and so we get the length of
VJ 0 which we know is false the length
of V J is 1 this is an orthonormal set
the length of all of the members of B
are 1 so we reach a contradiction this
is our contradiction VJ is not the zero
vector it has length 1 contradiction so
if you have a bunch of vectors that are
orthogonal and they're nonzero they have
to be linearly independent which is
pretty interesting so if I have this set
this orthonormal set right here it's
also a set of linearly independent
vectors so it can be a basis it could be
a basis for a for a or a subspace so we
can say let's say that B is the basis
for some subspace V or we could say that
V is equal to the span of we could the
span let me write it this way the span
of v1 v2 all the way to VK then we call
B if it was just a set we call it an
orthonormal set but it can be an
orthonormal basis when it spans some
subspace so we can write we can say that
B is an ortho normal orthonormal basis
for V now everything I've done is very
abstract but let me do some quick
examples for you just do you understand
what an orthonormal basis looks like
with real numbers so let's say I have
two vectors let's say I have the vector
or view one that is let's say we're
dealing in r3 so it's 1/3 2/3 2/3 and
2/3 and let's say I have another vector
V 2 that is equal to 2/3 1/3 and minus
2/3 and let's say let's say that
say that B is the set of v1 and v2 so
the first question is is what are the
lengths of these guys so let's take the
length the length of v1 squared is just
v1 dot v1 which is just 1/3 squared
which is just 1 over 9 plus 2/3 squared
which is 4 over 9 plus 2/3 squared which
is 4 over 9 which is equal to 1 so the
length squared is 1 then that tells us
that the length of our first vector is
equal to 1 is the square of the length
is when you take a square root so the
length is 1 what about vector 2 well the
length of vector 2 squared is equal to
v2 dot v2 which is equal to let's see
2/3 squared is 4/9 plus 1/3 squared is
1/9 plus 2/3 squared is 4/9 so that is 9
9th which is equal to 1 which tells us
that the length of V 2 the length of
vector v2 is equal to 1
so we know that these guys are
definitely normalized this is ami could
call this a normalized set but is it an
orthonormal set are these guys
orthogonal to each other and to test
that out we just take their dot product
so v1 dot v2 is equal to 1/3 times 2/3
which is 2/9 plus 2/3 times 1/3 which is
2/9 plus 2/3 times minus 2/3 that's
minus 4/9 minus 4/9 2 plus 2 minus 4 is
0 so it equals 0 so these guys indeed
are orthogonal so B is an orthonormal
set ortho normal set orthonormal set and
if I have some subspace let's say that
you know let's say that V is equal to
the span of v1 and v2 then we can say
that the basis for B or we could say
that B is an
ortho normal basis basis for V